[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos de nuevo el foco
en la sequía que azota a países como
Francia o España nos acompañan en este
estudio Andrea Hernández geógrafo doctor
en geoeconomía y urbanismo bienvenido
Oriana Romano es jefa de la unidad sobre
la gobernanza del agua de la ocde
bienvenida y mi compañero Rafael Morán
de la rúbrica vida en el planeta de
bienvenido Hola Carlos la sequía y la
gestión del agua en los países europeos
hoy nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
el presidente macron declaraba a finales
de febrero el fin de la abundancia del
agua en Francia a propósito de la sequía
que azota el país el jefe del estado
abogó por un plan de sobriedad del agua
siguiendo el modelo de la sobriedad de
la energía impulsada por la Guerra de
Ucrania la sequía recurrentes van a ser
la tónica en países como Francia o
España donde Por cierto estamos viendo
como la gestión del agua está en el
centro de la campaña electoral de las
elecciones autonómicas y municipales con
el parque de doñana en el centro de la
polémica no es el único caso de Las
Guerras del agua con los recursos
hídricos cada vez más escasos a todo
esto la ONU ya ha avisado que esta misma
semana que el período 2023-2027 será
probablemente el más caluroso jamás
registrado repasemos la prensa diario
libro pirineos sequía el plan de crisis
los pirineos orientales específicamente
es el punto de máxima alerta ahora mismo
en Francia el diario sud West se
pregunta en esta otra portada si hay
suficiente agua para las pis privadas
diario Liberación la sequía no se tomará
vacaciones con las zonas más críticas en
este mapa de Francia bueno andry por
hacernos una fotografía factual de la
situación ahora mismo parece que las
lluvias de los últimos días han aliviado
algo la situación en Europa salvo en la
Península ibérica confrontada a una de
sus peores sequías de su historia y aquí
en Francia el punto crítico lo situamos
en el departamento de pirineos
orientales lo primero que significa
decretar un estado de crisis como pasa
en este departamento del sur de Francia
Sí al decretar un estado que dices van a
cambiar puntos sociales y puntos
económicos sociales porque tiene que
haber un cambio de el uso del agua a la
lo que está acostumbrado a la población
en ese lugar y económicos porque hay un
turismo y fuerte que utiliza el recurso
agua con espadas con piscinas
que al venir a una un rubro que es más
tener el este criterio de el cuidado del
agua no se puede utilizar como siempre
se ha utilizado entonces va a crear
tanto social económicamente este impacto
en la en la zona
desde la base de Oriana qué se puede
mejorar en la gobernabilidad del agua en
un país rico para mitigar esta situación
es un asunto del que usted es experta Sí
claro yo creo que el problema de la
gobernabilidad del agua no se resuelve
con dentro del sector del agua sino
fuera con otras políticas sabemos que el
90% de los impactos del cambio climático
se manifiesta en el sector del agua de
forma de sequía de inundaciones Entonces
primero de todo es importante incorporar
las políticas de adaptación del cambio
climático en todos los procesos
políticos nacionales segundo un país se
puede incorporar decisiones de planear
de largo plazo incluyendo también en
partes interesadas que normalmente no
participan en planes entonces también
actores económicos y tercer punto es no
solamente incrementar la oferta sino
también la demanda entonces educación
concientización en el utilizo del agua
muy interesante lo vamos a volver sobre
esos puntos pero antes macron Rafa dijo
a los franceses lo hemos visto antes que
la abundancia del agua había terminado
claro a diferencia con España que ya
tiene una relación cultural más amplia
de más tradicional con la sequía el agua
ha sido un elemento menos considerado
infravalorado aquí en Francia
efectivamente en Francia hemos tenido a
veces en verano algunas que otras
restricciones locales
ha sido prohibido regar el jardín por
ejemplo o lavar el auto sin embargo
no no se ha visto muy poco casos como ha
ocurrido en algunas algunos municipios
de del sur de Francia que se han quedado
sin agua potable es algo que no se veía
desde hace muchos años y yo creo que eso
también ha llevado al presidente macron
y las reservas de agua las napas que
están en niveles en muchas regiones muy
preocupantes a decretar este
este plan de sobriedad decir ahora ya
vamos a tener que cuidar más el consumo
de agua es decir reutilizar las aguas ya
usadas algo que se hace ya en España en
Israel y que prácticamente no se hace en
Francia vamos a tener que inspirarnos de
estos países que sí saben hacerlo
también evidentemente luchar contra las
fugas en Francia el 20% del agua potable
se desaparece en las fugas y es algo que
sí también se puede trabajar para evitar
que se pierda toda esta cantidad de agua
y también evidentemente preparar los
episodios de sequía con una gobernanza
lo que comentaba usted más a nivel de
las cuencas hídricas y ya no tanto a
nivel de municipios para pensar mejor la
gestión del agua pues vamos a hablar
el propósito de lo que está comentando
mi compañero Rafael sobre esas
soluciones que se plantean tanto en el
plan que fue anunciado por macron y Hace
algunos meses como el de Pedro Sánchez
Hace tres semanas por ejemplo el tema de
las aguas residuales cómo funciona esa
reutilización de las aguas residuales
primero se te necesitan separar el tipo
de agua que se va y después En qué se va
a utilizar se tiene que hacer un manejo
no solo local sino más bien regional
como se habló Todo lo que es una un
ordenamiento más amplio una escala más
amplia no no tan puntual Entonces al
recoger esas aguas se van a implementar
en plantas que las van a limpiar y se
van a tener que redirigir ya sea para
ciertos usos no eso no es un agua 100%
potable al menos de que sea un agua que
se recupere de lluvia y pueda
potabilizarse Pero entonces Esas esas
políticas tienen que tener todo un plan
de reutilización y tener todo lo que es
un criterio a futuro de cómo se van a
utilizar las aguas y No simplemente usar
un agua reutilizada en cualquier aspecto
pueden ser utilizadas en riego por
ejemplo algunas
más posibles soluciones Soriana Rafael
Andrew me responde quien quiera las
plantas desalinizadoras por ejemplo Que
tanto se habla de ella se hizo una
solución que cuenta también con contras
porque claro Hay un coste energético a
sumar y por tanto es un agua más cara
más costosa y no tan ecológica como como
se podría pensar en un principio no
Cuándo hay que contar con ellas y cuando
no bueno por ejemplo a nivel mundial hay
un caso que es
mencionado en
[Música]
todos los casos de gestión de agua como
lo de Israel Israel es un país que sufre
de sequía de agua entonces con cinco
plantas desalinizadoras a partir de los
años 2000 ahora mismo tiene un 80% de
agua que depende de esta fuente que se
llama no un convencionales lo lo está
haciendo España con tres más de 300
plantas Entonces es una una de las
oportunidades pero claro y eso tiene un
coste un coste energético y también la
descarga de
substancias
tóxica también en el mar es uno de los
riesgos de este proceso en el sur de
Francia de hecho en esta región que
mencionábamos al principio de la del
programa en pirineos orientales y se ha
instalado una una planta de
desalinización
ambulante y diríamos que funciona con
energía solar porque estas plantas si
funcionan con con energía que producen
gases con efecto invernadero es una
aberración ecológica entonces bueno
algunas funcionan con energía limpia
está bien pero a ver
si genera una una un agua potable que
cuesta hasta entre 3 y 4 es más caro que
el metro cúbico normal y esto un país
como Francia o como muchos países
europeos que enfrentan una inflación una
crisis energética no se lo pueden
permitir ven qué soluciones mágicas Aquí
no hay aquí vamos una solución solución
por solución y vamos viendo que hay se
trata de muchas piezas que hay que ir
acoplando por ejemplo reducir al máximo
la fuga en redes de agua que se está
hablando también pero claro de Cuánta
agua estamos hablando en este caso y
cuánto cuesta ir a por esas fugas el
beneficio coste Andrés Sí el problema o
el asunto en Francia es que nunca se ha
tenido una conciencia del uso del agua
el agua a que ha sido realmente un
elemento que realmente la gente no sabe
ni siquiera cuánto paga de agua Cuánto
cuesta el metro cúbico de agua entonces
no se sabe cuánto se desperdicia no se
sabe cuánto se utiliza
en la ciudad la gente puede dejar el
Grifo abierto el agua corre y siguen
pagando lo mismo final de mes entonces
ahora ir a buscar todas esas fugas
puntuales en una red que realmente no
hace preocupado por eso que no sabemos
Dónde están las fugas que no sabemos es
un trabajo de inversión grande porque no
se sabe dónde se está exactamente
desperdiciando el agua pues aprovechando
lo que me dice Andrew hablemos de
conciencia y por tanto de tarificación
del precio del bolsillo el litro de agua
no puede tener un coste lineal tenemos
que acostumbrarnos a una tarificación
progresiva que penalice más a quién más
consume Oriana bueno el precio como
decía andrey el precio del agua es muy
limitado en los países del ocde cubre el
costo de operaciones pero por ejemplo
hay mucho más que hacer para mantener
una infraestructura que una las
infraestructuras del agua es una
infraestructura de las más vieja que
existen Entonces se permite alguna
pérdida de agua porque mantener renovar
la infraestructura va a ser muy muy cara
lo que existe hoy en día es una
sistemas de tarificaciones por ejemplo
también en cuanto
a una tarifa bloque por ejemplo cambiar
el precio de unidad del agua por
distintos bloques de extracción del agua
pero esto por ejemplo
una reducción del utilizo individual del
agua pero no cuenta con una demanda
agregada sobre todo en un periodo de
sequía entonces lo que se tendría que
hacer es una tasa sobre la extracción
del agua que sea capaz también de
incluir este riesgo de sequía una
tarificación que tenga en cuenta del
consumo de agua y claro tener en cuenta
de la redistribución porque hay personas
vulnerables
ciudades en Francia y que han instaurado
esta tarificación progresiva del agua y
con tarifas los primeros 100 metros
cúbicos que usted consume y les cuestan
un euro por metro cúbico luego de 120
metros cúbicos a 250 sube a uno un euro
40 el metro cúbico y si consumen más de
250 cuesta se duplica el precio cuesta
200 sobre 70 Eso me parece muy
interesante porque pues no es lo mismo
consumir determinados metros cúbicos
para el consumo doméstico
lavarse
cocinar que llenar una piscina regar un
jardín o un pasto privado en Francia que
saber que en el en el sur de Francia
sobre todo hay miles de piscinas hay un
Boom de construcción de piscinas
últimamente es el segundo mercado
mundial de piscinas individuales eso no
se ha reglamentado algunas algunos
municipios ya están prohibiendo la
construcción de nuevas piscinas Hemos
llegado ahí porque como mencionabas
andrey no hay esa conciencia de que
llenar una piscina una vez al año cuando
no viene a de vacaciones a su casa de
campo Pues tiene un impacto en el
consumo vamos a hacer en este punto una
breve pausa enseguida si la palabra
hablamos de más conceptos como la
policía del agua y también de la
educación que tenemos sobre el agua Pero
va a ser a vuelta de pausa hasta ahora
[Música]
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando las sequías que afectan a
países europeos como Portugal como
España o como aquí en Francia lo hacemos
con Andrea Hernández geógrafo Oriana
Romano jefa de la unidad sobre la
gobernanza del agua de la ocde y con mi
compañero Rafael Morán las restricciones
llenar piscinas lavar coches etcétera
Qué les parece André el concepto de
policía del agua y si el elemento
coercitivo en este tema en concreto debe
ser impulsado cuando la educación no es
suficiente en un tema que comienza a ser
tan sensible elemento coercitivo Sí sí
Lamentablemente cuando ya la gente no
hace conciencia Hay que entrar a lo que
es el castigo llamémoslo así entonces
pero medir En qué se utiliza el agua es
muy complicado no tener tendríamos que
poner un medidor para cada cosa para ver
que estamos donde estamos utilizando el
agua si es para una piscina si es para
bañarnos si es para comer entonces ese
es el asunto se necesita tener un un una
manera de poder
cuidar En qué se está utilizando el agua
es cierto el agua sigue siendo un
elemento fundamental y no lo podemos
restringir como estábamos hablando Hasta
cierto punto entonces Cómo medir Hasta
qué cierto punto es vital y después ya
es simplemente por gusto por lavar el
coche o llenar una piscina es difícil
hay que habría que cambiar desde por lo
menos la parte urbana los medidores
Porque no tenemos no sabemos Cuánta agua
utilizamos Y hasta qué punto ya se ponen
estos criterios de de de de castigo
pongámoslo así una sequía que además
hará que hablamos tanto de la inflación
con los costes de la energía también
afecta a que aumenten los precios de las
frutas y los verduras Y acaben siendo
bueno productos auténticamente de lujo
la escasez de lluvias puede provocar
Claro que pérdidas de cosechas pérdidas
de empleos los consumidores que tienen
que adaptarse a una nueva cesta de la es
decir hay mil consecuencias en esta
cadena de la que estamos hablando hoy
que afecta directamente a la economía y
otra consecuencia Tendría que haber una
adaptación de cultivos de la agricultura
hasta hasta nuevo contexto no Oriana la
una sequía cuesta en Europa 9000
millones de euros al año y se prevé que
para 2100 Este coste va a aumentar de 5
meses eso qué significa significa que
se van a reducir por ejemplo el tipo de
cultivos de entonces de Cómo se utiliza
el agua por alimentos se van a perder
puestos de trabajo ya por ejemplo en
2021 en California se perdieron por la
sequía 8.000 puestos de trabajo son
consecuencias
increíbles desde un punto de vista
económico sociales y también
medioambientales que tienes
consecuencias también con otro tipo de
desastre Como por ejemplo la inundación
misma
lo que se tendría que hacer Entonces sí
el cambio de cultivo puede ser una línea
de trabajo
el cambio en la demanda sabemos que en
2030 la demanda de agua va a aumentar de
un 55%, la población también aumenta
entonces todo esto con el cambio
climático y la reducción de la
disponibilidad del agua es algo que se
tiene que enfrentar hoy en día no hay
tiempo que perder y por tanto también lo
que vamos a ver aumentar son Las Guerras
del agua esa difícil maridaje también
entre Ecología y agricultura lo estamos
viendo estos días con el caso de doñana
en España como impacta en esas
elecciones
municipales y autonómicas es decir
Rafael que la gestión del agua creen que
va a ocupar cada vez más espacio
político también en los países europeos
sin duda en Francia en las últimas
elecciones no fue un tema a nivel
nacional a nivel local Sí ya está
haciendo un tema de preocupación y de
fricción también este ejemplo de un
alcalde del sur de la región Parisina
que está en guerra contra una planta de
coca-cola que está bombeado bombeando
agua en la Napa freática y este alcalde
quiere que ya se se limite esta este
esta captación de agua y tenemos
ejemplos mucho más violentos y
preocupantes y que tienen que ver con la
agricultura en Francia hay esta política
de construcción de Mega embalses muy
controvertidos porque precisamente se
llenan bombeando agua de napas freáticas
los ecologistas las organizaciones
civiles ambientalistas y los partidos
ecologistas Están en contra precisamente
porque eso es como una carrera sin fin
para alimentar un modelo agrícola basado
en la exportación para producir
alimentos para los animales y también
para regar cultivos y para una
agricultura extensiva que no es para
producir
frutas o verduras que comemos a diario Y
eso yo creo que en algún momento se va a
tener que replantear no no siempre en
España también es lo mismo
llegar un momento en que se te se va a
tener que repensar este modelo agrícola
que ha pues generado muchas ganancias
pero que no va a ser eterno en un
panorama de crisis climática con sequías
más recurrentes más frecuentes y menos
precipitaciones no vamos a poder
Eternamente seguir regando unos cultivos
que están destinados a la exportación
únicamente vemos que al final claro hay
dos patas en este banco la política que
se va a tener que encargar de gestionar
todos estos asuntos de los que estamos
hablando las opciones políticas que se
les presenta a los ciudadanos los
partidos van a tener que hablar cada vez
más de este tema y también la educación
y la conciencia del propio ciudadano es
decir no olvidemos también la
responsabilidad individual en este tema
o sea hay ambas no sí sí hay que cambiar
la conciencia ya no se puede utilizar el
recurso agua como antes ya no se puede
utilizar tanto como para una economía ya
no se puede utilizar tanto para el ocio
la gente tiene tiene que ver No solo la
gente sino el ordenamiento territorial
tenemos que ver cómo vamos a reutilizar
esos recursos ese recurso que ahora es
más escaso cuando nosotros estamos
todavía jóvenes se decía que el agua era
un elemento que nos iba a acabar nunca y
nos hemos dado cuenta que sí entonces
todas estas generaciones de economía
toda esta explotación del agua Nunca
tuvimos la conciencia para cuidarla
ahora en la parte política sí va a haber
muchas presiones políticas entra un
juego como como de ganar un espacio para
tener más acceso al agua entonces los
políticos pueden oponer soluciones o
restringirlas Y eso afecta a la hora de
elegir verdad Y también como se hagan el
corto plazo de largo plazo porque claro
por ejemplo en el caso de doñana estamos
viendo también que y se intenta
beneficiar una agricultura de unos
espacios que no deberían
que no deberían destinarse a ello pero
claro los votos también juegan en estos
casos en el corto plazo en el largo
plazo Rafael querías Añadir algo más
por supuesto que es importante la
concientización individual pero ahí hay
el estado y los gobiernos y los
responsables políticos tienen que tomar
cartas en el asunto para garantizar la
equidad la justicia social no es normal
No es aceptable que el municipio que
tenga los recursos para instalar una
planta de desalinización pueda hacerlo y
finalmente pues mantener el suministro
de agua potable y que otra otro
municipio que no tienen esos recursos no
lo pueda hacer no es normal que un
agricultor que pueda costearse
un la construcción de un mega embalse
tienen tenga garantizado el suministro
en agua y que su vecino que no ha pagado
no no no no no no construido este mega
embalse no tenga acceso al agua ahí hay
un tema de de Justicia social y
hablábamos de de medidas coercitivas Sí
claro que pueden ser puede haber medidas
coercitivas pero es el estado que tiene
que ser garante del acceso universal y
barato a al agua para satisfacer las
necesidades básicas es por eso la idea
de del manejo del agua no puede ser de
un punto de vista de una escala local
tiene que ser una escala regional
nacional porque una cuenca no va a haber
un municipio una cuenca abarca
diferentes municipios de donde se
reabastece el agua quién utiliza el agua
Cómo Cuál es el fin y Y quién va a
cobrar el agua entonces es un trabajo de
ordenamiento territorial escalas tampoco
se puede poder sobre el agua en la
ciudad sino De dónde viene el agua que
se va a utilizar en la ciudad Oriana
desde la ocde hacéis mucho hincapié en
un concepto que me gustaría que
explicaras que es el de seguridad
hídrica En qué consiste
seguridad hídrica consiste en el hacer
que la gente tenga acceso a un agua
disponible que sea que sea limpia más o
menos cada uno Podría tener acceso a un
100 litros de agua perdida y luego
proteger o contra los riesgos o que
llame que llamamos de demasiada agua o
sea en inundaciones poca agua o sea
sequías y agua contaminada lo que quería
Añadir a este discurso también en
político es que el marzo pasado todos
los gobiernos mundiales y más de 10.000
personas que trabajan en el sector del
agua pero también en el cambio climático
se han encontrado en una conferencia en
New York en Nueva York que después de 50
años ha sido la segunda conferencia
mundial sobre el agua después de vez en
cuanto años entonces una señal
importantísima para subrayar el rol del
agua en el cambio climático error del
agua
como justicia Social para darle acceso
al agua potable a todo el mundo Entonces
en muchas medidas se han tomado en como
consecuencia de esta conferencia
entonces
inversiones los Estados Unidos van a
invertir más de 50.000 millones de
dólares en infraestructura en varios
planes se se han sacado de ahora en
Europa sabemos el plan de de Francia
sino también en Alemania hay varios
decretos también sobre las equien y tal
entonces
medidas de reglamentación de medidas de
financiación
será el más caluroso jamás registrado
según la ONU Esto va a tener
repercusiones importantes sobre la salud
sobre la seguridad alimentaria y también
sobre la gestión del agua lo dice el
propio el propio organismo qué retos va
a plantear este escenario que vaticina
la ONU y que es a corto y que por tanto
los políticos no pueden esquivar porque
hay temas que puedes dejar aparte pero
aquí la realidad está en tozuda que está
que no es algo no es una proyección de
del cambio climático de mañana es ya es
Ya por eso se necesitan tomar acciones
inmediatas planes inmediatos que a veces
no son los mejores pero es que no queda
otra es que ya no hay tiempo sí a ver
datos tenemos sabemos cómo va a
funcionar un ecosistema ya sabemos En
qué punto crítico se encuentra
las decisiones se pueden tomar pero es
que viene un aspecto político muy
importante que por más que tengamos
datos los científicos las organizaciones
internacionales llega un nivel donde son
los políticos los que van a ser que esas
valgan donde hacen políticas locales o
esas políticas regionales del uso del
agua se pongan en marcha Entonces es Ahí
viene la presión también habrá que ver
si el interés del votante en buscar eso
en los programas políticos este tipo de
soluciones que esto también habrá que
verlo No si hay un interés del votante
en este de temas Rafael interés de los
sectores concernidos porque en Francia
por ejemplo el principal sindicato
agrícola francés fnsa de corte
conservador hasta ahora no ha mostrado
ninguna señal de querer cambiar un
modelo que le ha generado
rentas desde hace medio siglo con una
agricultura basada en la hiper
productividad y obviamente este
sindicato tiene muchas muchos vínculos
muchos nexos con el mundo político
francés lo que augura pues como decía
fricciones de la que de las que
seguramente volveremos a hablar pues
estaremos muy atentos a las fricciones
muchísimas gracias me quedo sin tiempo
para más ha sido un placer Oriana Rafael
Andrew y a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana quien en Primera Plana de
cifras 24 gracias